My name is Erin Driver-Linn,
and I am no longer the Director
of HILT. Yes, I am the dean for
education at the Harvard T.H.
Chan School of Public Health--
best school in the
entire university.
[LAUGHTER]
It's got an amazing,
amazing mission.
Amazing students,
amazing faculty.
I'm having a great
time five weeks in.
I have the honor of
introducing our new president.
Many of you will have been
reading lots about him.
Many of you will be
attending his inauguration
and you'll hear more about him.
There is a bio in the
program, so I'm not
going to do the
standard introduction.
I will tell you a little
story about the first time
I met President Bacow.
It was in 2011-- and he
will not remember this one.
He remembers a lot of
things, but he will not
remember this one.
It was at a kind of event,
and there was a buffet table.
And I was talking
with a friend of mine,
and she said,
that's Larry Bacow.
And I said, oh.
And she said, do
you know who he is?
And he said, no.
[LAUGHTER]
She said, just joined
the corporation.
Former president of Tufts.
Used to be at MIT.
I was like, oh, wow.
I probably should
have known who he was.
She said, I want to say hi.
Do you think that
would be too forward?
I said, I don't know,
do you know him?
And she's like, a little bit.
But I think he remembers
people, and I think he'd be OK.
[LAUGHTER]
And then she said, he's the kind
of person I want to work for.
And I said, why?
And she said, because
I'd learned a lot.
And I said, in a good way?
[LAUGHTER]
And she said, absolutely
in a good way.
He is through and
through an educator.
And no offense, not in that
like teaching and learning way,
but really, he knows stuff.
He's a role model, and
he gets stuff done.
And I really remembered that.
She interrupted him as he
was loading up his plate
and reintroduced herself.
And introduced me quickly
and I gracefully left.
But I remember that.
All of those components, the
educator through and through,
not in the teaching
and learning way,
which is kind of interesting.
And that he deeply cares
about learning and teaching
and it's part of who he is.
And so we invited him to
our first TILT conference,
and he said yes and
he came quickly.
And-- I mean, he answered
quickly, not everybody does.
Since he's been more
part of my mattering map,
I've had the great occasion of
working with him several times.
And the thing is, so many
of you have also had that.
And it's another part
of my observation
here, which is that he--
President Barkow engages.
He shows up, he is
involved, he is constantly
learning from all of us,
from every interaction,
and he's constantly teaching.
And I am really excited about
this next phase of Harvard's
history, and what
we're going to do
with this institution
in this next era.
And I am happy that
he is at the helm.
And you'll have to
forgive me for this,
I hope he also has
a hand on the HILT.
Please join me in
welcoming President Bacow.
[APPLAUSE]
Wow.
I've been introduced quite a few
times recently, here at Harvard
and elsewhere, but I
don't think I've ever
had an introduction quite
as nicer or as personal
as that one, Erin, so
thank you very, very much.
It's really great to be here
on so many different levels.
As Erin said, I was present
here at the very first HILT
conference.
And Erin really helped to
bring this whole enterprise
into the world.
And when we think about
what we do with our lives
and what we accomplished and the
people that we influence, Erin,
through your good work, through
helping to elevate teaching
and learning on the
agenda for Harvard,
you've had a profound
impact on a place
that I think really matters,
and I think all of us
should thank you at
this point for helping
to make this happen.
[APPLAUSE]
But nobody gets anything
done on their own,
and there are
other people who've
been involved here as well.
And I just want to take
a minute and acknowledge
Peter Bol, Harvard's
first Vice Provost
for Advances in Learning.
And I also want to
acknowledge his successor,
and that's Bharat Anana and
his colleague Dustin Tingly,
who I think are
going to continue
the great work that Peter
and Erin have really
started on our behalf.
As I like to say,
nothing succeeds
in life like a successor.
And we are fortunate that
we have good ones here.
As Erin mentioned, and
I also just alluded to,
I was fortunate to be here
for the very first HILT
conference in 2012.
What she didn't mention, though,
is that that was actually
my first public appearance
as a member of the Harvard
Corporation anywhere.
So this is where I--
like my coming out as
a corporation member.
And I remember serving on
a panel with Youngme Moon,
with Alan Garber, and
with Michael Sandel.
And in retrospect,
the title of the panel
was quite prescient,
because it said--
it was entitled-- remember this?
"Looking to the Future."
Now I must say, I could not have
imagined this future [LAUGHS]
at the time, but as I
often say to my students,
the best piece of career
advice I can give them
is to recognize opportunity
when it walks up and hits you
in the face.
And in the interest
of full disclosure,
I did not go looking
for this job,
but I also could not
turn away from it,
because these are difficult and
challenging times for higher
education.
I see this as an opportunity
not just to lead Harvard,
but to be an advocate for the
enduring values of colleges
and universities and
higher education more
broadly as enablers of
the American dream for so
many of us.
And I would hope that
all of you would see that
as part of your
work, your mission
as well in trying to advance
teaching and learning.
But here I am.
I should also disclose to
you that this is the Harvard
Initiative for
learning and teaching,
but it was really kicked off by
two extraordinary people, Gus
and Rita Hauser, whose
gift made this possible.
And again, the
world is connected
in very interesting ways.
I was the first Hauser
Leader-in-Residence
at the Kennedy School
after I stepped down
as president of Tufts.
And so I remember at the
HILT conference thanking
Gus and Rita for their
generous gift, which made
all of this good work possible.
And then I had a
second opportunity
to thank them when I was
appointed as the Hauser
Leader-in-Residence.
And now that while
they're not here,
maybe they're watching,
because Rita is very
good at watching things online.
Gus and Rita, thank
you again for all
that you have made possible.
I was talking to Bob Kerrey, who
you will hear from a little bit
later today, about
some of the challenges
that we face in
higher education--
as we face as Harvard.
And one of them is that
we are perceived as elite
at a time in which that
has become a dirty word
in the United States.
In fact, I like to
say, the only thing
which seems to be an appropriate
word to be modified by elite
is quarterback.
To be an elite
university is bad,
to have an elite quarterback,
that's OK, people like that.
And I prefer to think that
what we stand for is not elite,
but rather, we stand
for excellence.
We stand for excellence in
everything that we do here.
And one of the things which I
feel so good about with respect
to HILT is that you
have really elevated
our commitment to excellence
in teaching and learning.
And just looking at what's
happened in the seven years
since the very first
conference, people
are talking about how
do students learn.
We're digging into data,
we're mucking around
and trying to understand the
information, the meaning of all
the clicks and the online
work that's being done,
and sorting through
the big data that way.
In thinking about how we teach,
especially with technology
that's forced us to reflect
much harder about how
we organize our information.
What are our students
actually learning?
And so I think this is an
incredibly interesting time
at Harvard, as faculty and
students and staff and others
are really focused in a
very concentrated, deep way
in trying to understand how
we can do a better job to help
our students learn--
how we understand different ways
in which our students learn,
because one of the things
which we appreciate
to a much greater degree
is that not all students
learn the same way.
How do we adapt our
teaching so that--
and now I will use an MIT term--
there is a far better impedance
match between what we're trying
to-- the information we're
trying to convey and the way in
which our students understand
it.
We become sensitive to
all of those things.
And as a result, I think we're
a much better institution
as a result.
But I want to issue a
challenge for all of you
today in your work.
And the challenge is this--
the reality is, only a very,
very small number of students
are ever going to
study at Harvard.
And so the challenge
is, how do we
think about what
we are doing here
and what we are
learning here, how
can we ensure that that
benefits all of the students who
are seeking to get an
education in the United States?
Four out of five
kids in the US are
going to be educated at the
great public universities
of America.
And I think it's
imperative that we take on
as our responsibility
that what we do here
translates elsewhere.
That we reach out,
we extend ourselves,
we try and help
other institutions,
and that we do so as
true partners, OK?
Not we're from Harvard and
we figured out how to do it
and here we are,
but rather where
we engage with
other institutions
as humble partners, as
generous partners, where
we try to learn from them and
we try to share what we have
learned here with them as well.
That is a true partnership.
Because we need to ensure that
the lessons that we learn here
benefit and help everybody,
and the education of students
who will never set
foot in Harvard Yard,
never even see the
city of Cambridge.
So today I ask that you
begin thinking through some
of these questions, some of
these critical issues, which
are so important, I think, for
all of us in higher education--
for the values
that we stand for,
and I hope you will
also help to join me
as we seek to try and change
this narrative about higher
education.
That to help people
understand that we
exist not to make
Harvard great, but rather
to make the world better.
And that that, ultimately, is
what we are doing here today.
So thank you very much for
inviting me to join you.
Good luck with the work
that you will do today.
I'm sorry that my
schedule will not
permit me to sit in
and attend, but I
have the privilege of ending
my day with Erin wearing
her other hat at the
School of Public Health,
and she's told me
that she's going
to give me a full and complete
report on your conversations.
So thank you all very
much and have a great day.
Take care.
[APPLAUSE]